allô allô ici la terre vous m'entendez
le temps prochaine matos bon j'arrive
ça va vous m'entendez tout va bien bon
bonjour aujourd'hui je suis content de
retrouver parce que on va parler de la
batterie de votre téléphone portable
et sachez que les batteries c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment un problème
sur ces saloperies et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
[Musique]
alors si on parle de téléphones
portables à temps il fut une époque où
les téléphones portables ça ressemble à
ça parce que vous avez connu nokia 33-10
un modèle qui a cartonné et à l'époque
pourtant nos batteries elles durer
beaucoup plus longtemps qu'avec les
derniers modèles
alors on se demande pourquoi parce qu'en
réalité les technologiques vous aviez là
dedans
elle était quand même moins bonne que ce
que vous avez actuellement dans tous ses
téléphones là mais on l'utilisé pour
téléphoner on joue aux serpents on
envoyait des sms et le téléphone durée
carrément plus longtemps alors pourquoi
et comment y remédier c'est vraiment une
question intéressante alors le pourquoi
ben je vais pas en cause dans le domaine
technique parce que je pense que
globalement ça n'intéresse pas grand
monde mais surtout le comment y remédier
ça c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
la consommation de nos batteries n'a pas
arrêté d'augmenter les batteries se sont
améliorées elles durent plus longtemps
telle surcharge beaucoup plus vite mais
par contre la consommation elle explose
littéralement
alors il ya une solution pas il existe
une ou plusieurs solutions pour
améliorer sa batterie significativement
pour pouvoir avoir un téléphone qui dure
quand même plus d'une journée
ce que en règle générale je sais pas -
mais quand on utilise son téléphone
si on arrive à le garder charger une
journée c'est déjà le bout du monde donc
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on a découpé
cette vidéo en trois parties alors
rassurez vous c'est les petits partis je
regarde dans mon cahier la toute
première partie mais on va regarder la
recharge comment recharger est-ce qu'il
faut la recharger tout le temps la vider
complètement lui vint une charge
complète donc on va regarder un petit
peu de ce côté là pour voir ce qu'il en
est le deuxième point on va regarder
l'analyse de sa consommation savoir
comment consonnes pourquoi ce qu'ils
valent mieux ce qu'ils valent moins bien
et puis comment l'améliorer
et puis ensuite le troisième point et
lien hop voilà ce sont les optimisations
de son téléphone j'ai toutes les notes
là il suffit pas d'arriver de l'allumer
la caméra et de shooter et puis on se
lance dans la préparation quand même
donc on va commencer tout de suite par
le premier point le tout premier point
c'est la recharge de son téléphone heure
fut une époque où on vous disait votre
téléphone il faut qu'il soit
complètement déchargées pour pouvoir
ensuite leur charge et vous lui mettez
une charge complète dans next décharger
complètement pour ensuite le recharger
et 11 et ses grands cycles vide plein
vide plaint tout le temps maintenant
c'est plus le cas maintenant c'est plus
la pète vous avez plus besoin de faire
ses grands cycles votre téléphone ce
qu'il faut que vous fassiez c'est que
vous laissez pas décharger complètement
vous laisse à rêver vert
10 5% vous pouvez mettre une charge même
en charge et plus tôt et vous n'êtes pas
obligé de laisser charger jusqu'à 100%
vous pouvez l'arrêter plus tôt c'est pas
un problème
recharger le quand vous en avez besoin
alors si vous voyez vraiment la batterie
des fois elle se décharge
bizarrement et que ça me pose vraiment
problème moi ce que je vous conseille
cette fois quand même des grands sites
complets voulu décharger complètement
vous rechargez à fond qui vont regarder
comment ça se passe ça continue vous
faites une mise à jour de votre os et ça
continue vous réalisez votre téléphone
c'est peut être un problème logiciel
mais actuellement sur les batteries
qu'on n'a plus besoin de faire des
grands cycles comme on the hill époque
et ça c'est quand même plutôt sympa ce
qui fait que quand vous avez cinq
minutes samuel millions dans un endroit
vous branchez votre téléphone vous leur
charge est quasiment à 50% voire même
davantage
et vous pouvez en profiter ensuite ça
c'est un point positif autre point qui
est vraiment intéressant faut faire
super gaffe c'est que les téléphones ont
tendance à un petit peu à chauffer quand
ils chargent alors si vous voyez votre
téléphone chauffe quand il charge moi ce
que je vous conseille ses dents mais
votre coque tout simplement parce que ce
qu'elle va faire votre joli petit coq
sont loin des coques comme ça sont des
espèces de plastique s'avoue guerre
vraiment la chaleur et ça c'est pas très
très bon pour votre téléphone parce que
votre batterie
elle va chauffer davantage ce qui fait
que la chaleur elle va être vraiment
conserver ça ça chauffe ça bullguard
cette fortune vous gardez un
environnement hyper chauffer c'est pas
bon pour votre batterie donc si vous
avez votre téléphone me chauffe quand
vous leur charge et vous enlever ça vous
laisse échanger tranquillement et
ensuite vous remettez et vous allez voir
que ça sera vraiment vraiment vraiment
positif pour votre téléphone 19.1 hyper
important et on y fait souvent attention
je ne sais pas si vous faites comme moi
ou comme la plupart des gens quand le
soir quand on va se coucher qu'est ce
qu'on fait on a tendance à brancher
notre téléphone et on laisse sur sept
heures toute la nuit le matin on
débranche il repart avec magnifique me
direz-vous parce que du coup vous a dit
vince est bon il est chargé il est prêt
le matin sur quand je parle il est à
100% je peux dégager ma journée
sauf que laisser un téléphone branché
alors qu'il déjà 100 % c'est pas très
très bon donc dans la brousse qui vont
vous fassiez c'est que vous branchez
votre téléphone quand il ya 100 %
avouent débrancher et basse
or vous dirai je vais pas m'amuser à me
réveiller la nuit il mettra réveil pour
télécharger à 100%
partir ou alors réveillé deux heures
avant mon heure de réveil est normal
pour brancher mon téléphone pour être
sûr qu'il soit à 100% ce moment là mais
dans l'absolu il vaut mieux faire comme
ça parce que si vous laissez votre
téléphone tout le temps la batterie
chargée en permanence déjà ils risquent
de chauffer et même si geof pas il ya
des fonctions est fondamentalement c'est
une très mauvaise idée
maintenant on va passer à l'analyse de
sa consommation maintenant qu'on sait
comment gérer son téléphone qu'il faut
faire pas faire les bonnes pratiques
on va regarder comment vous vous
consommez et comment améliorer tout ça
il faut savoir que dans vos smartphones
que soit de laïos ou de l'android vous
avez un petit menu à l'intérieur qui
vous permettre de connaître exactement
la consommation de votre téléphone
ce qui fait que vous allez savoir
exactement ce que consomme vos
applications et comment améliorer ça
alors moi retenir on va regarder on va
acheter un petit coup d'oeil ensemble
alors je suis sur un os donc android
c'est très simple si vous êtes dans vos
paramètres vous avez vous trouvé moi je
vais dans réglages je vais dans je ne
suis plus je ne sais plus je vais dans
batterie une fois dans batterie
j'attends que ça change parce que mon
truc qui rame qui n'en peut plus alors
ça y est chargé maintenant vous avez ici
des dernières 24 heures vous avez les
deux derniers jo et vous avez une petite
icône horloge donc je clique dessus ça
ne met le temps que j'ai utilisé ça ne
met le temps en arrière-plan et ça c'est
un indicateur qui est vraiment très
intéressant parce que vos applications
vous a effectivement l'utilisation que
vous vous en faites lorsque vous allez
dessus puis vous aller naviguer sur
internet sur facebook soit des mecs soit
autre chose et vos applications elles
travaillent en arrière-plan
elle travaille en tâche de fond et elles
vont vraiment utilisé de la batterie est
consommé et ça s'est vraiment bien ça me
permet de vous rendre compte du travail
un petit peu qui se fait complètement de
façon invisible et qui pourtant va
consommer énormément de batteries alors
moi ce que j'utilisais plus au cours des
dernières 24 heures c'est facebook sept
minutes à l'écran quand on dire que je
suis pas le calme très grande victoire
c'est safari 19 minutes et youtube cinq
minutes à l'écran oui j'ai encore pas
particulièrement sur mon téléphone je
suis plus sur une tablette dont les gens
m'aiment beaucoup youtube pour ça il
faut savoir est par contre en
arrière-plan pour avoir utilisé par
exemple facebook 16 minutes
j'ai cinq minutes d'arrière-plan alors
j'ai souvent pensé je sois en économies
d'énergie ni son nom apparaît après faut
vraiment faire attention à toutes ces
consommations là parce que vous pouvez
avoir beaucoup
applications qui vont travailler en
arrière-plan qui vont consommer et que
vous pouvez fondamentalement vraiment
améliorée donc je t'aime petit coup
d'oeil à votre consommation regarder ce
qui va consommer de plus est-ce que
c'est par exemple je sais pas moi un
signal chatte est ce que c'est un
facebook est ce que c'est un instagram
sont des emails et toutes les
applications qui consomment énormément
en arrière-plan
moi ce que je vous conseille ces données
désactiver fin du moins d activer la
consommation de l'arrière-plan donc ce
que vous faites
que ce soit sur un os ou sur android
vous allez dans vos applications dans
votre menu applications et vous trouver
une application par contre moi je vais
prendre les facebook ça qui me concerne
et de plus je vais
sur facebook on voit qu'ils à la case
actualisé en arrière-plan qui est
activée et du coup ça c'est un mauvais
plan donc je le désactive est comme ça
il pourra plus actualisés en
arrière-plan et moi au moins je sais que
je consommerai pas trop alors pour vous
soyez pas trop en détail toutes vos
applications comme ça qu'ils vont le
travail en arrière-plan sur ios ça
existe sur android je sais pas à
vérifier ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
activer le mode économie d'énergie alors
sur un os on sait facile vous monte
alors moi je vais rajouter ici ici
j'active là et mes applications non plus
la possibilité de travailler en
arrière-plan fait exactement la même
chose sur android et vous allez voir que
vous allez économiser de la batterie
sans laisser des petits détails et à
force de petits détails on finit
vraiment par avoir un gain à la fin et
ça c'est intéressant
l'idée dans tout ça si vous voulez que
celles autorisées que les applications
que vous utilisez réellement vraiment un
sens pour vous pourquoi avoir des tonnes
d'applications qui vont travailler en
arrière-plan de toute façon vous n'avez
pas besoin si par exemple vous en fichez
qu'une application ou une autre soit
tout le temps en train de récupérer des
données des e-mails par exemple ça peut
avoir un sens si vous attendez beaucoup
10 miles et de limeil professionnels sas
a un sens mais il ya des applications
qui vont consommer énormément qui vont
travailler en arrière-plan qui
fondamentalement vous vous en foutez
donc optimisé s'acheter un petit coup
d'oeil et vous allez voir que vraiment
ça va changer les choses
en plus d'être arrière plan de
l'application vous pouvez vraiment les
ut les optimiser pour la géolocalisation
pourquoi forcément utiliser toutes vos
applications qu'ils demandent à on
pourrait avoir la géolocalisation ça a
globalement peu d'intérêt et c'est
pareil ça consomme pas mal pareil pour
la notification est ce que vous avez d
intérêt à ce que toutes vos applications
heureusement des notifications alors il
ya certaines c'est bien pour avoir des
messages d'un ami des choses comme ça il
y en a d'autres franchement vous en
foutez avant moi j'ai l'application
marmiton
j'ai bien dormi tôt quand je cherchais
de recettes mais par contre je m'en
fiche que tous les soirs à 18h30 ou 17
heures ils m'envoient leur recette du
jour parce que de toute façon du jeu pas
forcément le temps de deux chais pas les
ingrédients et puis de trois voilages
chose à [ __ ] c'est tous les petits
détails vous affiner sa et vous allez
voir que vous allez vraiment économiser
en batterie et en plus de ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en regardant les
statistiques des applications que vous
utilisez le plus vous voyez laquelle
vous rend le plus sadique sur lequel
vous passez plus de temps vous permettra
peut-être de savoir à quel moment il
faut décrocher quand on passe plusieurs
heures
collé sur son écran à être tout le temps
sur l'application bon il faut peut-être
un moment se remettre en question les
dire que bon il va peut-être falloir un
petit peut être un peu moins dépendants
troisième point comment
optimiser son smartphone parce que
maintenant que vous savez comment
utiliser votre batterie correctement que
maintenant vous savez dans les
applications qui consomment le plus et
comment régler je dirais vos
applications maintenant finir par
optimiser tout est là il ya pas mal de
petits réglages qui mis bout à bout
peuvent vraiment améliorer la
consommation de votre batterie et j'ai
pris mon petit bloc note pascal à plein
et je veux pas les oublier alors je suis
perchée sur l'espèce de tabourets je
sens que dans 5 minutes je vais par
terre ce folk la catastrophe
si vraiment votre batterie vous êtes au
bout du bout vous ne pouvez plus et que
il vous reste allez on va dire 20% de
batterie et que par contre vous devez
tenir encore deux heures avoir deux ou
trois heures il va falloir vraiment
aller chercher dans les tous les recoins
héraclès qu'on peut raclée pour gagner
leurs batteries alors ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est déjà désactiver la
géolocalisation
ça vous le désactiver ça va pas
forcément chercher tout le temps où vous
êtes et vous allez économiser active et
le verrouillage automatique de votre
écran à une minute ça franchement faut y
penser
passé un truc tout con mais en règle
générale lorsque vous le poser sur une
table de téléphone qui est quelque part
vous avez une application ouverte a pas
besoin de rester allumé tout seul dans
son coin pendant cinq minutes jusqu'à ce
que mort s'ensuive
vous mettez un réglage par défaut à une
minute quand votre application quand
votre téléphone pardon est posée et bien
un moment bien tout simplement se
désactiver s'éteindre écrans noirs et là
paf économies d'énergie un autre qui pas
con pour l'économie d'énergie qui marche
très bien
woods tout à fait la gueule c'est de
mettre un fond d'écran pour noir qui
fait que vous allez consommer quand même
beaucoup moins
et mine de rien quand on voit la taille
des écrans sont aujourd'hui c'est pas
con si vous êtes en intérieur que vous
voulez connecter à l'activé plutôt le
wifi plutôt qu'utiliser la kadji ou la
troisième aux dépens ou est-ce que vous
êtes fait les mises à jour de votre os
ça je vous disais tout à l'heure mais je
le redis encore là parce que c'est
important
les mises à jour alors pas forcément sur
les grandes versions mais je dirais sur
l'épisode day pour corriger des bugs
ça peut être vraiment intéressant parce
que des fois votre rêve silva qu'on
sonne et naturellement alors que en
corrigeant un bug et bien vous allez
consommer beaucoup moins et vous allez
retrouver avec une batterie qui durera
plus longtemps
pensez à désactiver le bluetooth si vous
n'utilisez pas baisser la luminosité de
votre écran alors ça déjà c'est bien
pour votre batterie merci pour vos yeux
parce que l'amour
je fais une luminosité je dirais à peu
près normal ça s'est tout de suite
en règle générale je suis plutôt moi là
dessus
alors il n'y a pas un écart qui énorme
mais par contre vos yeux vous diront
merci et votre batterie aussi donc là
c'est double effet kiss cool pareil pour
vos emails lorsque vous voulez connaître
vos emails c'est pas la peine qu'ils
travaillent en tâche de fond aller les
récupérer plutôt manuellement vous allez
forcément économiser c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure lorsque vous
avez des applications qui travaillent en
tâche de fond et ben ouais ça consomme
donc vos emails c'est la même chose vous
vous dites choquée mais je vois ce qui
se passe ailleurs je vais faire tout de
suite moi au paf les mails alors c es
hommes ça c'est bon c'est gérer il ya
beaucoup de mails des messages
voilà il y en a plein donc vous allez tu
vous connectez vous rafraîchissez ça
doit occuper vos emails
qu'est-ce que ça va changer du fait que
vous arriviez lice mais se récupérer ou
alors vous glisser et vos e-mails
l'appareil franchement c'est une
économie de temps qui est minime par
rapport à ce que vous avez gagné en
batterie des deux côtés pareil
désactiver la mise à jour automatique
des applications saas quelque chose qui
va travailler tout le temps qu'il faut
mettre la dernière application à jour et
lorsque vous êtes dans d'économiser de
la batterie basse à meucon sommet pour
rien faites vos mises à jour
manuellement et vous allez voir vous
allez vous y retrouver si vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de batteries pensez à
désactiver série cortana il vous dit
quanti fermer toutes vos applications
qui sont otages de fond ça c'est souvent
un truc con on a pleins d'applications
qui sont là voulaient fermer tout un
boubou rider vous fermez savent où me
fermer ce allez allez allez allez allez
allez allez allez allez
et voilà on économise un petit peu c'est
parce que je fais tout ça ouvert sa
sortie de désactiver regroupe sur votre
iphone aussi vous pouvez désactiver le
fond d'écran dynamiques pour économiser
encore un peu lorsque vous êtes en mode
sonnerie couper les vibrations ou sinon
vous pouvez aussi baisser le son de
votre sonnerie comme ça sonnera moins
fort et ça économisera un petit peu au
niveau de part leur tour mais je vous
dis ça c'est quand même des des petits
trucs à grand chose mais tout mis bout à
bout
voilà c'est son plein de petits points
qui je vous dis forcément pris
indépendamment n'avons pas changé la
face de la consommation de votre
téléphone
mais tous mis les uns après les autres
vous allez voir que vous allez avoir un
téléphone qui va durer plus longtemps
parce que de toute façon je vous le
disais il vous lisant des bêtes vidéo il
faut être hyper logique pourquoi 1,3310
consommerait pas grand chose et à
l'époque en fin du mois pour les
or comme moi quelque chose près et pas
désagréable dans mon commentaire
pourquoi est-ce que ce vieux truc ils
consomment du plat est normalement et
pourquoi est ce que ces nouveaux trucs
ils consomment énormément et la vraie
réponse
elle vient en partie d'où elle vient en
partie de vous elle vient de votre
consommation
aujourd'hui on est devenu addict avec
ces trucs là on passe vachement de temps
sans différentes applications c'est vrai
que toutes ces grandes sociétés ses
développeurs travaillent là dessus pour
qu'on devienne de plus en plus vite et
qu'on passe beaucoup de temps dessus
mais un moment rare il faut aussi que
nous on arrive à responsabiliser
mais faute de vous raisonner et c'est
vraiment du tout optimisé pour que ça
consomme pas énormément et qu'à la fin
de vie une batterie qui dure quand même
plus qu'une journée et vous votre
téléphone
est ce que vous arrivez à garder un peu
plus d'une journée un peu moins d'une
journée est ce que vous pensez à être
addict à certaines applications parce
que ça c'est vraiment un sujet
intéressant on s'en rend pas forcément
compte on en a pas conscience mais on
passe énormément de temps à utiliser des
petites applications souvent de deux
conneries 1
ça nous prend beaucoup de temps vous
mettez sans commentaire on va en
discuter ensemble
dites-moi si votre batterie vous pensez
qu'elle est quand même optimisé vous
mettez tout ça je vous invite à mener
c'est tous ces commentaires envoyés de
l'amour et bien plus encore à me laisser
des jolies pousse toujours des gens me
pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on va
parler d' encore plus de nouveautés
encore plus de tutos encore plus
d'astuces pour optimiser bon là on a vu
la batterie pour optimiser l'appareil
photo pour optimiser la consommation
utilisation de vos appareils high tech
abonnez vous connectez vous je vous
embrasse je vous dis à très bientôt
soyez sages portez vous bien et on se
retrouve très bientôt
toc toc
[Musique]